[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
willkommen beim Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesen Mittwoch die vom Sport hat
Norbert Lehmann der Familie wir haben
unter anderem diese Themen für Sie
wer hat Recht nach dem Absturz einer
Drohne im Schwarzen Meer machen sich USA
und Russland gegenseitig Vorwürfe
Kampf gegen Trockenheit und Dürre
Deutschland schmiedet eine
wasserstrategie um die Versorgung zu
sichern
und Krawalle vor dem Spiel vermummte
Anhänger von Eintracht Frankfurt
randalieren vor der Champions League
Partie gegen Neapel
[Musik]
russische Kampfjets stoßen über dem
Schwarzen Meer auf eine US-Drohne das
ist wohl die erste direkte militärische
Konfrontation zwischen Russland und den
USA seit Beginn des Ukraine Kriegs
entsprechend groß ist die Sorge vor
einer Eskalation die USA machen Russland
für den Absturz der Drohne
verantwortlich Moskau bestreitet jede
Schuld
es geht um eine Drohne vom Typ Reaper
ganze Elfmeter lang sie kann bewaffnet
und für gezielte Angriffe genutzt werden
laut US-Militär war sie aber zur
Aufklärung im internationalen Luftraum
unterwegs nach dem Vorfall südwestlich
der Krim beginnt jetzt das Wettrennen um
ihre Bergung Axel Konrad
zwei russische Kampfflugzeuge treffen
auf eine US-Drohne über dem Schwarzen
Meer soweit die von beiden Seiten nicht
bestrittenen Fakten dann aber gehen wie
so oft in diesem Krieg die Darstellungen
entscheidend auseinander während die
Russen die Drohnen nur begleitet haben
wollen schildern die Amerikaner den
Vorfall so
mehrfach sprühten die beiden jetskerosin
auf die Drohne ein Chat touchierte dabei
den Propeller der mq9
manövrierunfähig musste das Fluggerät
zum Absturz gebracht werden
dieser gefährliche Vorfall ist Teil
eines Musters aggressiven riskanten und
unsicheren Handelns russischer Piloten
in internationalem
aber täuschen Sie sich nicht die
Vereinigten Staaten werden weiter
fliegen und operieren wo immer ist das
internationale Recht erlaubt
nicht klar bislang war die mq-9
bewaffnet
diese Drohne kann 1700 Kilo Sprengstoff
transportieren kann Bomben tragen was
würden wohl die Amerikaner machen wenn
eine russische Drohne sehr nah sagen wir
auf San Francisco oder New York zu
fliegt
nicht Zerstörung sondern Informationen
so die Expertenansicht der eigentliche
Sinn des drohnenfluges
die US-Drohne war im internationalen
Luftraum durfte darum fliegen rechtlich
ist es sehr eindeutig genauso eindeutig
ist das Russland das nicht mag weil
diese Drohnen und auch bei Mante
Aufklärungsflugzeuge natürlich da sind
um
Aufklärungsergebnisse über die
russischen Streitkräfte zu gewinnen war
der Absturz der Drohne dann eher Kalkül
als Unfall
also das darf man auch nicht vergessen
das ist ein ein feindliches Objekt also
da ist natürlich der Auftrag auch der
Piloten dieses Objekt auch entsprechend
herunter zu holen russland hat jetzt
angekündigt die abgestürzte Drohne aus
den Tiefen des Schwarzen Meeres Bergen
zu wollen
MRT Wissen in Washington wie wollen die
Amerikaner das verhindern
also wie du die US-Regierung will es
verhindern kann es aber vermutlich nicht
sie haben nämlich keine eigenen
Kriegsschiffe im Schwarzen Meer auch
keine bergungskapazität man müsste den
Nato-Partner Rumänien bitten oder eine
kommerzielle Bergungsfirma damit
beauftragen was man immerhin gemacht hat
ist dass man die komplette Software und
alle Daten die Steuerungstechnik
gelöscht hat in dieser Drohne und sie
damit vielleicht keinen großen Wert hat
wenn Russland die Bergen sollte
ähnliches wird Verteidigungsminister aus
den in einem Telefonat zu einem
russischen Amtskollegen vorhin gesagt
haben von dem wir jetzt erfahren haben
wenn die Russen sich entscheiden doch
die Drohne Bergen zu wollen dann wäre
das eine weitere Provokation sie liegt
im internationalen Gewässer ist
amerikanisches Eigentum und es wäre ein
Signal dass wir weitere Provokationen
sehen könnten zumal die Amerikaner auch
weiter Drohnen in dieser Region
einsetzen wollen
danke für diese Einschätzung aus
Washington Elmar Thesen war das
Bundespräsident Steinmeier besucht
Estland vor dem ukrainekrieg wäre das
wahrscheinlich ein Routinetermin von
mittlerem Interesse gewesen doch jetzt
ist das Baltikum mit seinen direkten
Grenzen zu Russland in erhöhter
Alarmbereitschaft und in Estland hört
man genau darauf wie sehr sich
Deutschland bei der Sicherung der
nato-ostflanke engagiert Patricia
Wiedemeier berichtet
es war diesmal kein Alarm kein
feindliches Flugzeug in Sicht ganz im
Gegenteil zwei Eurofighter begleiten die
Maschine des Bundespräsidenten beim
Anflug auf den Militärflughafen emri
Rheine Übungsflüge hier arbeiten
deutsche und britische Soldaten seit
neuestem zusammen kontrollieren
gemeinsam den Luftraum über dem Baltikum
beide Staaten stellen jeweils 3 €
Fighter Technik Wachdienst Flüge alles
in deutschbritischer Kooperation die
Botschaft die wir von hier aussenden ist
ganz klar die NATO ist bereit jeden
Quadratzentimeter ihres bündnisgebietes
zu verteidigen das sagen wir auch zum
Schutz der Menschen die hier in den
baltischen Staaten leben wir kommen
unser nato-verpflichtung nach wir
übernehmen diesen gleichen Auftrag in
Deutschland ja auch wir stellen auch da
die NATO alarmgrotte sicher die unter
der gleichen Führung ist wie hier vor
Ort und da haben wir auf jeden Fall alle
Mittel die wir brauchen haben wir hier
vor Ort Aussagen die man im Inland kaum
hört auch beim anschließenden mit dem
Präsidenten von Estland viel Lob für den
deutschen Einsatz
Deutschland spielt die zentrale Rolle in
der kollektiven Verteidigung der NATO
auf dem Schlachtfeld und bei allen
Entscheidungen es ist das sechste Land
an der nato-ostflanke dass der
Bundespräsident besucht seit Ausbruch
des ukraine-krieges er will diesen
Ländern die um ihre Sicherheit fürchten
weil sie nahe Russland liegen zeigen
dass Deutschland an ihrer Seite steht
konkrete versprechen und zusagen kann er
nicht machen doch der Besuch hier in
Estland es ist ein Zeichen der
Solidarität mehr allerdings nicht
auch ein Zeichen und ein Signal an
Russland zweimal täglich starten
deutsche und britische Jets und
kontrollieren den Luftraum
[Applaus]
wenn Deutschland seine Klimaziele bis
2030 erreichen will dann muss es Tempo
machen vor allem der Verkehrsminister
das zeigen Berechnungen des
Umweltbundesamts
seit 1990 sind die Emissionen des
klimaschädlichen Treibhausgases um rund
40 Prozent gesunken auf 746 Millionen
Tonnen im vergangenen Jahr das Jahres
soll 2022 erfüllt hat der Bereich
Industrie schleppender läuft es dagegen
bei Gebäuden im Verkehr und in der
Energiewirtschaft haben die Emissionen
sogar zugenommen Henriette de Maiziere
ein blamierter Bundesverkehrsminister
der die Klimaschutzziele verfehlt so
sehen es die Protestierenden vor der
Bundespressekonferenz drinnen stellt das
Umweltbundesamt seine Zahlen vor die
Bilanz durchwachsen vor allem beim
Verkehr geht mehr CO2 in die Luft wir
haben wieder höhere Mobilität wir sind
aus Corona raus das ist hat einen
entsprechenden Effekt auf der auch auf
die Treibhausgasemissionen wir haben
insgesamt 9 Millionen Tonnen zu viel was
den Verkehrssektor angeht laut
Schätzungen des Umweltbundesamtes sinken
die klimaschädlichen Treibhausemissionen
leicht um 1,9% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
das ist vor allem einem Rückgang in der
Industrie zu verdanken Sorgenkind der
Verkehrssektor die FDP will nun die
Ziele der einzelnen Sektoren anpassen
wir werden auch in Zukunft erleben dass
in manchen Sektoren gewisse Reduktionen
schneller geht wir hatten während der
corona-pandemie gesehen dass zum
Beispiel im Verkehr die Missionen
deutlich gesunken sind und so ist kein
Jahr miteinander vergleichbar deswegen
ist es wichtig dass wir uns ein
mehrjährigen Gesamtrahmen anschauen und
dass wir sektorübergreifend schauen wie
sich Emissionen entwickeln die
Koalitionspartner zwar einig bei den
Klimazielen doch bei den Maßnahmen unein
IG man löst die Klimakrise am Ende ja
nicht dadurch dass man einfach versucht
sie weg zu definieren und das wäre es ja
wenn man die Situation Ziele aufgibt
nicht mehr hinschauen löst noch kein
Problem alles in allem eine eher
dürftige Bilanz um das Klimaziel bis zum
Jahr 2030 zu erreichen müssten nun die
Emissionen jährlich um 6 % gemindert
werden
eine Folge des Klimawandels Wasser wird
knapp auch in Deutschland deshalb hat
das Kabinett heute einen nationale
wasserstrategie verabschiedet um die
Versorgung sicherzustellen
hier sehen wir wie die Böden in den
vergangenen zehn Jahren immer stärker
von Dürren betroffen waren mittlerweile
leiden auch die Grundwasservorkommen was
helfen kann zeigt Andreas
was haben Pappeln und Wassergewinnung
miteinander zu tun relativ viel sagt
Biobäuerin Maria die Minish rund um Ihre
roggenfelder im brandenburgischen
märkisch-wilmersdorf hat sie die Bäume
gepflanzt die Pappe ist in der Lage
Wasser einfach auch aus tiefen Schichten
wieder nach oben zu holen und dann auch
für andere Pflanzen verfügbar zu machen
und unter jedem Baum ist der Boden
eigentlich wie so ein Schwamm
Wassergewinnung mal ganz anders Pappeln
als Boden Befeuchter jeder Ansatz ist
willkommen in den eins ist klar
Deutschland trocknet aus Wasser der
Ursprung des Lebens wird knapper auch
hier bei uns
wir haben in der dürrejahren an vielen
Orten ungefähr ein Meter
Grundwasserspiegel verloren wir werden
also sehr lange brauchen um diese
Defizite wieder aufzufüllen und das
merkt man auch deshalb hat die
Bundesregierung die nationale
wasserstrategie auf den Weg gebracht
künftig sollen per Fernleitungen
wasserarme Regionen versorgt werden
außerdem legen Leitlinien fest wer wie
viel Wasser verbrauchen darf in der
Industrie perspektivisch in der
Landwirtschaft muss es von vornherein
auf einen sparsamen Umgang auf Wasser
Wiederverwendung auf brauchwassernutzung
ausgerichtet sein weil wir das nicht
alles in Zukunft weiter mit Trinkwasser
in der bisherigen Form bewältigen können
auch ohne politisches Eingreifen hat
Maria gimenisch ihr
wassergewinnungsprogramm längst
gestartet ich finde das in der Politik
noch lange nicht genug gemacht wird
dafür um Landwirte zu unterstützen
nämlich solche noch alternativen
Methoden umsetzen zu können hier in
märkisch-wilmersdorf funktioniert
jedenfalls
seit sechs Jahren mit Hilfe der Pappel
seit dem Wochenende sind die Börsen
weltweit nervös von einer möglichen
Bankenkrise ist schon die Rede auslöser
war die Pleite zweier US-Banken auch
hierzulande fielen die Kurse der
Finanzhäuser heute die nächste
beunruhigende Nachricht das Schweizer
institut-suisse derzeit Europas größte
problembank ist massiv unter Druck
sina-meinitz an der Börse in Frankfurt
droht da die nächste Bankenkrise also
davon ist erstmal nicht auszugehen bei
der Schweizer Bankkredit Suisse hat es
schon länger finanziell gekriselt und
sie gilt in der europäischen
Bankenlandschaft auch als Einzelfall der
saudische Großaktionär die Saudi
Nationalbank hat nun angekündigt der
Kredit Suisse kein weiteres Kapital mehr
zu geben und das sorgt nun zusätzlich
für Misstrauen bei Banken und Anlegern
auch in Deutschland Frankreich Spanien
und Italien wurden heute Bankaktien aus
den Depots geworfen Papiere der Kredit
suis verlieren zum Handelsschluss 24 %.
hierzulande müssen die Aktien der
Deutschen Bank und der Commerz Grund 9%
ein das sieht auch den deutschen
Aktienmarkt mit nach unten der DAX
verliert heute knapp 500 Punkte und
steht am Ende bei
14.735 Zählern Volk sollte
beschwichtigen und sind sich einig eine
Wiederholung der Bankenkrise wie nach
der Lehman Pleite gäbe es nicht die
Notenbanken würden das schon verhindern
und auch die Europäische Zentralbank
wird ihrem Kurs wohl treu bleiben und
morgen den Leitzins vermutlich um einen
halben Prozentpunkt anheben dankeschön
für die gestiegenen heiz- und
Stromkosten hatte die Regierung schon im
September allen Studierenden einen
Ausgleich versprochen dann gab es viel
hin und her seit heute aber können die
rund dreieinhalb Millionen berechtigten
die Einmalzahlung von 200 Euro
beantragen allerdings erneut mit
Problemen zeitweise war die
entsprechende Plattform völlig
überlastet nach Frankreich dort hat ein
Vermittlungsausschuss des Parlaments den
Weg frei gemacht für die umstrittene
Rentenreform sie könnte schon morgen
endgültig verabschiedet werden heute
sind deshalb wie hier in Paris erneut
tausende Menschen auf die Straße
gegangen begleitet wurden die
Demonstrationen von Streiks seit Wochen
gibt es in Frankreich Massenproteste
gegen das Anheben des
Renteneintrittsalters von 62 auf 64
Jahre
vor allem Kinder und Jugendliche lieben
die kürzen Videos von tiktok die
chinesische App ist weltweit ein
Riesenerfolg auch Firmen Politiker und
Medien versuchen dort Fuß zu fassen um
die jungen Nutzer zu erreichen doch die
EU-Kommission und das
parlamentspräsidium sagen jetzt Stopp
Mitarbeiter und abgeordnete müssen die
App von ihren Diensthandys löschen aus
Sorge vor chinesischer Spionage Gunnar
Krüger hat mehr
schnell noch ein Bild ein Post bis
Montag müssen auch EU-Abgeordnete tiktok
vom Diensthandy löschen Europa Politik
auf der unterhaltungsplattform
Selbstwert damit Erfolg hat spürt ein
Unbehagen das bedeutet dass all die von
euch die drauf geklickt haben das tiktok
Zugriff auf das Mikrofon hat die ganze
Zeit abgehört werden können von tiktok
mancher der China kennt hatte nie ein
tiktok Konto und seinen Grund dafür
Daten die von solchen chinesischen Apps
gesammelt werden sind nicht geschützt
gegen den Zugriff der totalitären
chinesischen Regierung die eu-banking
Daten und um Technologie bei Eindhoven
sitzt der Weltmarktführer für
mikrochip-maschinen Ausfuhren nach China
und der sagte jüngst die niederländische
Regierung es geht um den Technologie
Vorsprung und die nationale Sicherheit
die USA drinken die nieder Freunde zum
ausfuhrstopp die Technologie ist ein
Trumpf des Westens im Nachtkampf mit
China denn nur so haben wir überhaupt
noch eine Stimme in China und können
auch
ok ausüben das heißt hier ist ein sehr
sehr
vorsichtiger Balance abgefragt sowohl
der Politik als auch der Wirtschaft bei
tiktok und Chip-Technologie folgt die
eu-grad demselben Trend mehr Abstand zu
China
mehr als einen Monat nach dem Erdbeben
Leben in der Türkei immer noch
Hunderttausende in Notunterkünften und
sind jetzt heftigem Regen ausgesetzt der
hat Überschwemmungen ausgelöst
mindestens 13 Menschen kamen ums Leben
die meisten in Sanierung fahr hier
verwandelten sich Straßen in schlammige
Flüsse die zahlreiche Autos mit sich
rissen
deutsche Studierende forschen nicht nur
an der Uni sondern bald sogar im Weltall
nicht persönlich aber ihre Experimente
laufen auf der Raumstation ISS das
Material dafür transportiert ein
dragon-frachter des Unternehmens space x
er startete in der Nacht von Cape
canaral in Florida ein Projekt
beschäftigt sich mit demenzforschung es
untersucht wie Zellen in der
Schwerelosigkeit altern morgen soll der
Frachter an der ISS andocken
andocken und jetzt zur Champions League
Norbert da gab es krawale vor dem Spiel
der Eintracht ja die Präfektur Neapel
die hatte ja verboten vorab das
Frankfurt Fans überhaupt den Stadion
dürfen aus Sicherheitsgründen das war ja
auch vielfach kritisiert worden trotzdem
sind hunderte Eintracht Fans nach
Italien gereist ja und vor zwei Stunden
kam es zu heftigen Auseinandersetzungen
mit der Polizei in der Innenstadt
Alexander Ruder in Neapel wie ist denn
die augenblickliche Lage dort
also wir stehen inzwischen am stadio
Diego amando baradona und hier ist die
Situation zumindest aktuell noch ruhig
aber tatsächlich ist es am Nachmittag in
der Innenstadt zu schweren
Ausschreitungen zwischen Eintracht
Anhängern und der italienischen Polizei
gekommen nahe der Piazza del Jesu
lieferten sich beide Seiten eine
Straßenschlacht Frankfurter Ultras
sollen dabei mehrere Autos in Brand
gesetzt haben darunter ein Polizeiwagen
zudem wurden Tische Stühle Schaufenster
von Bars und Restaurants zerstört also
die rund 400 gewaltbereiten Ultras waren
zunächst bei ihrem Arsch durch die Stadt
durchgeblieben aber danach eskalierte
die Situation und wie das hier nachher
am Stadion weiter geht können wir
natürlich jetzt noch nicht sagen alles
was wir wissen ist dass die Frankfurter
Eintracht eine Null zu zwei Niederlage
aufholen muss danke für diese
Information Alexander oder nach Neapel
ja gestern Abend hat Leipzig sein
hellblaues Wunder in Manchester erlebt
0:7 gegen City und ein hellblauer stand
da bei Mittelpunkt oerling Holland als
fünffacher Torschütze stehen der
Ovationen für Erwin Holland bereits nach
63 Minuten von pep Guardiola
ausgewechselt damit dem 22-Jährigen noch
Ziele bleiben mit insgesamt fünf
Treffern in einem Spiel stellt der
ehemalige Dortmunder den Champions
League Rekord von Messi und Adriano also
erstmal nur ein spektakulär ist trotzdem
egal wie viele Leipziger ihn zu bändigen
versuchen die norwegische Urgewalt
Holland macht sie zu Statisten fünf
Treffer zum 7:0 schmerzlich für Leipzig
aber ein echtes Freudenfest für Holland
und alle Höhepunkte der Spiele von
gestern und heute Abend bei uns zu sehen
in Sportstudio Champions League und 23
Uhr
zwei deutsche Topplatzierung beim
letzten abfahrtswirtbewerb der Saison in
Andorra ein nahezu perfektes Rennen von
womit Baumann er wurde Zweiter sein
erster Podestplatz in diesem Weltcup
Winter ja nur 400stel dahinter sein
Teamkollege andreas Sander auf Rang 3
Sieger der Österreicher Vincent
kriechmayer der größte Erfolg für die
deutsche Männer in dieser alpin
Königsdisziplin seit Moment ich habe es
mir aufgeschrieben 31 Jahren das musst
du noch gesagt werden vielen Dank
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 3 17 19 34 39 44
und die Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
morgen wird es etwas wärmer und etwas
wärmer und etwas sonniger mehr dazu hat
gleich als den terli viertel vor zehn
begrüßt Sie Marietta Slomka im
heute-journal und hier übernimmt morgen
metri Siren ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend sag Danke und auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter milde Luft
erreicht uns vor diesem Tief auf dem
Atlantik und ein kleines Zwischenhoch
das sorgt auch noch dafür dass es
vorübergehend auch etwas ruhiger wird
aber ganz im Nordwesten da ziehen
kompakte Wolken durch und das Blau hier
das bedeutet dass da etwas Regen
rausfällt in der Nacht ist es fast
überall trocken nur ganz im Süden am
Alpenrand letzte Schneeflocken hier im
Südosten da bildet sich Nebel und
überfrierende Nässe ist da ebenfalls
möglich vor allem bei diesen
Temperaturen bis -6 Grad nach Südosten
hin und drei Grad plus ganz im Westen
aber oft Temperaturen unter der Null
Grad Marke morgen dann vor allem im
Osten viel Sonnenschein nach Nordwesten
sind die Wolken kompakter die ziehen
einmal durch und etwas Regen ist dabei
sonst ist es trocken bei Temperaturen
zwischen 6 und 8 Grad ganz im Norden und
16 Grad in Südwesten ein paar shower
gibt es dann durchaus am Freitag im
Norden sonst aber nach Süden vor allem
Sonnenschein 11 bis 21 Grad und ab
Samstag gibt es ein paar Gewitter dazu
damit ein schöner Abend